alex all right a really important  message this morning safety advocates  are reminding all of us drivers to watch  out and leave room for cyclists  today's event is really is really meant  to  make sure that motorists and all users  of the roadway  notice cyclists on the side of the road  notice that we're there  recognize that we need to give them  space so you don't take somebody's loved  ones  from them so a number of local law  enforcement agencies joined together for  the spike safety event it was yesterday  now nevada law does require drivers to  give cyclists three feet or just simply  move over a lane when possible  180 citations were handed out in just a  few hours  this comes just after five cyclists were  killed on u.s 95  near searchlight that happened earlier  this month